طائره تسقط لا لبس في الصوره
سقطت ربما او اسقطت بنيران دفاعات جويه
كما نقلت عن موقع مقرب من فاجنر لا شيء
مؤكد على قائمه ركابها يظهر اسم
لكن لا تاكيد حتى الان انه استقل الطائره
فعلا فكل شيء خامض في مسيره الرجل منذ
صعوده المثير للجدل وانخراطه في عمليات
عسكريه متزامنه في بقاع العالم من الشرق
الاوسط في سوريا وليبيا الى اوكرانيا
والحرب عليها ثم افريقيا قبل ان يقود
استعراض قوه مفاجئا يقول كثيرون انه لم
يكن موفقا في الداخل الروسي فهل كتب اخر
سطور مسيره بريجوجن
قبل ايام معدوده
ظهر الرجل في تسجيل المصور رفقه مسلحين
كثرت التكهنات حول مكانه افريقيا على
الاغلب قال كثيرون فالتسجيل ياتي في وقت
يشهد فيه غرب القاره متغيرات استراتيجيه
كبيره على صعيد التحالفات القديمه
والجديده قبل هذا باسابيع قال الرئيس
البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاتشينكو ما فهم منه
انه احتوى ابن الكرملين الضال واستقبله مع
مقاتليه في قاعده عسكريه قرب العاصمه منسك
وما رافق ذلك من غموض تام للصفقه التي
ضمنت خروجا امنا لبريكوشن بعد ان سير
مدرعات فاجنر في شوارع مقاطعات روسيه وكاد
ان يقترب من موسكو نفسها لتحل ليله الثالث
والعشرين من اب اغسطس اي بعد شهرين من
التمرد كما سمته موسكو خبر مقتضب يتحدث عن
سقوط طائره خاصه قرب موسكو تسارعت الانباء
على متنها عشره اشخاص يملكها وكان على
قائمه ركابها خبر مفصل يقول ان فرق البحث
انتشلت 8 جثث من موقع الحطام من اصل عشر
وان طائره ثانيه يملكها ايضا هبطت بسلام
في احد مطارات موسكو فاين هو يفجين